so what is the right kind of crazy is
when you live a life at 120 miles per
hour it does take a certain amount of
crazy for people to jump out of plane
get in fire fights a lot of things up
all that luggage has no place to go but
hit you in the back of the head whose
paper bat like this alright to get hit
with something like you just saw a
newspaper can be dangerous enough to
give someone a concussion certainly not
amount how do you view how China looks
at us how easy would it be for them to
put a hundred million people but
parachutes on their back and fill our
skies and you've got intellectual
property the potential of them being
inside your network they've been in
there for five years before they were
actually caught you think there is the
meddling going on with election I think
the investigation proved that ads were
paid for by corn and at ease eighty-five
percent of it was exaggerated wrong or
wasn't even close what are your
philosophies and views on how to handle
active shooters it doesn't take much for
some people with mental health to flip
that switch trust your eyes question
your ears when you fight you're fighting
for your life you're going to make the
wrong decision and end up dead
[Music]
so today's guest is a former member of
the NSA SEAL team 3 as well as special
mission unit he wrote a couple books
another one that's coming out here as
well called the right kind of crazy and
the one book he wrote just recently
that's got nearly 2,000 reviews on
Amazon called 100 deadly skills we're
gonna be talking today to Clint Emerson
Clint's thanks for coming out here
thanks for her at you for coming out so
you know I'm reading this book obviously
we're gonna spend some time talking
about that one here but I'm going
through the hundred deadly skills and
you got a chapter that says how to steal
a plane which everyone needs to know how
to steal a plane robbers you know you
got another one that says how to
discrete and lose surveillance which is
great we need to know that and then you
know how to dispose of a body which is
insane to me so I looked at this book I
said listen it's Clint writing this book
for us for for citizens to learn how to
do this are you writing this book for
the bad guys so what inspired you to
want to write this book there was a
couple of things all right so first
getting out of the military right as you
transition you go from hero to zero you
look for things to do yeah a friend gave
me an opportunity to write a book we
were supposed to do it together
he'd already published a bunch of books
and I said sure well then he's an older
guy so he ended up having back surgery
and left me hanging and I was left to
finish this thing but I knew that when I
got out I wanted to kind of go down the
path of crisis management and this is a
great way an entertaining way an
informative way to get consumers to take
a little bit more ownership in their own
personal security and safety but I also
knew there was some tactics that in
order to get the attention of media guys
like you you've got to throw some taboo
stuff in there and certainly the skills
plus a couple of others that you
mentioned certainly get the attention of
people but ultimately I really did want
to get a book out there that everyone
could learn from I like to joke that
it's probably the most popular book
sitting next to a man's toilet in
America without a doubt it's Illustrated
for all of those army crayon
then like pictures in the yes I'm just
kidding yes
but yeah that's that's the shorter
that's what makes it helpful them and
when you look at it the pictures you
know for some of us won't point near GPA
folks we need basic illustration you can
show know how to do this but it's a tell
me let's go through a couple of them
before we go into your story here sure
with the book so how do I steal a plan
you know how do I go about stealing a
plan well first you have to not fly it
kind guy that's that's that's a big
problem but if you do know how to steal
a plane and you happen to be on a run on
the run in a semi permissive
non-permissive environment then you go
to a delta airspace Airport which is
your smaller airports some of them have
towers some of them do not but the goal
is that's a less environment for
security so therefore you'll be able to
gain and get out discreetly and on top
of that it's usually the hangars in
those smaller airports have smaller
aircraft so a single-engine land
aircraft is what you'd be going after
and a lot of times these things were
built in the 70s they don't have like
you know these high speed locks on the
doors so if you're going after cessna's
or Piper's really it's all about the
magneto switch which is what gives
everything power the prop is the crank
and a lot of these we'll start with just
that kind of simple knowledge on top of
that if it's got an increased ignition
system then being able to pick the lock
to start and then magneto switches and
then pull in the prop and it'll start
right out just be careful when you pull
the prop you got to get your arms out of
the way real quick yeah something could
happen to your on disappear
let me ask y'all this stuff you learned
when you were in as a seal yourself
where in case you're in war something
happens you got try to get away you have
to learn how to fly plane and steal a
plane or is it more for entertainment
purposes it's a little bit of both
in the later part of my career I
certainly experimented with alternative
ways of getting yourself out of trouble
it became really important to think
about and think about things you know if
hey okay what if worst case scenario
what am I going to do I just happen to
be a pilot it was something I went
my own and and then I yes I did add it
to the book for entertainment value god
yeah how much how many of these hundred
have you actually used in war and
experience for yourself where it's
firsthand not something you're just
writing about probably fifty percent or
more of those that's a good amount yeah
when you talk about some of the
surveillance based uh right um we we get
into that in the community when you talk
about some of the more personal security
and how to be the the grey guy in
society especially when you're traveling
the globe when I talk about third party
awareness personal awareness cultural
awareness all of those things are
mentioned a book those are all really
important to lesson yourself as a target
when traveling abroad whether you're a
tourist or you're a guy like me it just
applies to so many different
environments hell in this country alone
if you go from one city to the next you
can find yourself in trouble because you
don't understand that city's culture
right so it applies everywhere very true
yeah that's good to know because
sometimes you know you write a book and
hey seventeen keys to success and a guy
wrote it he's never done a business
before both these are things that you've
actually applied yourself and seen
whether it's in wartime or in your own
personal life as well write a whole
bunch I've applied about 50% or more
applying to work I'm betting in civilian
life you haven't dispose of a body you
know I'm a betting man interview
mobsters and other guys you're a seal
I'm betting that hasn't happened yet so
so so I had a captain Duncan Smith on
okay and anytime I bring folks from the
FBI or NSA or CIA or seal or anything
that worked at the highest level and
military ask him what do you think the
biggest threat were facing today right
for you everyone has their own opinion
on this
you're you seem like the guy that's very
astute you pay attention to details all
this stuff about where you see it like
when you go into a room you know that
whole one scene you were looking at
where Matt Damon is saying the guy
sitting at the you know that one movie
scene he's sitting here poor cars park
does he like well not to that point but
you could kind of pay attention to it
right what do you think is our biggest
threat right now it's a former Navy SEAL
military guard what do you see as our
biggest threat today well I think
there's multiple threats there's an
acronym I came up with called
threat thre 80 it's a great way to break
down threats in any environment you find
yourself the first one is technical
threats which is audio video your mobile
devices cyber really is the umbrella to
that one I think that the cyber front is
the wild wild west it's not regulated
there's a lot of threats they're both a
consumer the government we've even seen
at work to potentially sway elections
here in the United States along with
overseas so I feel the cyber world is
the next frontier
mainly because everyone has a device in
the palm of their hand connectivity is
very easy and there's a lot of nefarious
characters out there that want to take
advantage and exploit everyone who
actually has a device so that's that's
number one and then you've got the H
which is health threats
I mean we're rolling into flu seasons so
all of a sudden that will be number one
in the media within a couple of months
so and then of course when you talk
about active shooters and under health
is also making sure you know stopping
the bleeding is something good to know
and that you've got to be aware of and
then R is really your violent crime
raids robbery and ransom I feel like
those are domestically a big deal with
the increase in active shootings 2018 we
had 450 plus workplace related active
shooters workplace workplace active
shooters 450 plus of them in 2018 having
no more employees by the way how many
they were from outside I mean there were
actual employees a lot of times there's
the big three on how you break down
active shooters and why mental health
right is a big one relationships okay
and that relationship is defined as
relationships at home or in your private
life relationships at work with a
supervisor a peer or a subordinate my
sense so and then in third place is
usually money is the other reason people
come and start shooting so you know you
have to be you know you have to be aware
of that and domestically I think that's
it
obviously a big threat it's at the
forefront of everybody's mind these days
and so you've got at least be thinking
about it when you the rest of the
threats e environmental threats you know
you've got 900 tornados a year in this
country you've got hurricane season
going on right now so those are always
something that's there and they're very
seasonal and so you got to be aware of
it
a is another invisible threat that we
all deal with and we don't even know it
is agencies working against us that's
foreign Intel services that's law
enforcement that may pull you over in
foreign lands where bribery is a second
form of income and if you don't know
that then you'll go to jail instead you
believe that I do believe that even in
America a lot is happening and when you
go overseas definitely buy Oreos the
second I think most of them make more
mouth from Iran I I know what it is to
say go you go into politics to make more
money than stay in the civilian world
you can do additional ok and then T is
the is the one threat that will never go
away and that is terrorism
so in short to answer your question when
you talk about what is the threat that's
most concerning are the one that keeps
you up at night
it really depends on where you sleep
each day right so the point being is you
really have to know your environments
and know the threats that could
potentially happen in those environments
in order to answer that question
accurately and it's the one thing I push
all day every day is that hey just know
what those threats are in your
environment the clues and those cues and
then you can elude those threats all
together and never have to face them but
you got to know about them you got to
get educated on them and you've got to
stay like you set the beginning you know
in the Jason Bourne video you got to be
at least 50 percent aware and put your
phone away in order to you know know
what's going on put your phone away what
am you put your phone away put your
phone away because we are attached to
our phones right we're on
oh we honestly would constantly have our
head in our mobile devices when in
reality we need to get our heads up and
looking around simple simple so what is
something about many of us are doing to
know we need to know so with some of
these let's go through this let's go
rude a technical with cyber okay I'm in
a financial industry and one of the
things I'm noticing happen more today is
when I'm going to conferences with other
CEOs and these large hundred 200
billion-dollar insurance companies five
years ago no one's talking cybersecurity
but maybe for two minutes okay
ten years ago no one even talks about
cybersecurity okay we're going into you
today everyone's talking about
cybersecurity
without a doubt would when I tell you
everyone every meeting I'm going to
indifferent insurance everybody saw my
cybersecurity so let's go through the
basic stuff of cybersecurity okay the
most basic way for me to protect myself
when I'm dealing with cyber security
password is there any specific rules you
follow for picking passwords for your
bank account for your social media for
your phone and is there anything you
recommend on ways to keep your password
so because sometime when you have to
remember 50 different passwords for 50
different places you save it in a place
so you can go to it or do you have
something you recommend so let's start
off with the most basic thing password
how do you view passwords
I think passwords still are the number
one vulnerability at an individual level
okay and because of that that's what
makes companies vulnerable and so the
hackers they know this and these days
hackers aren't usually you know the kid
in the basement of his mom's house you
know yelling for a cheese sandwich
and sitting there trying to get into
someone's information a lot of times
they are programmers putting together
these packets of malware and attaching
them to links or trying to you know
discreetly inject them into a network so
that an entire system is affected but
when you back up to the simple stuff
like passwords the rule I follow is 24
characters or longer okay and that
sounds crazy but the reality is is if
you type in a phrase that has zero
attribution to you your family your
personal life your dog's your
anniversary dates nothing personal and
you put in a phrase now within that
phrase you can have you know changing
characters you can add in some symbols
so instead of s's you can use the money
symbol right
but a phrase the beauty of this is that
phrase usually you can type it a lot
faster because we're used to home keys
and we know or our fingers know where
they're going and they tend to be able
to type that phrase whatever you choose
a whole lot faster than some crazy
complex combination of letters numbers
and symbols right but the idea is is
when you go past the 24 character mark
what you're doing is actually eluding
any of those malware packages that or
packets that can run a virus against
your username and password they can run
at usually 500 characters a second right
trying to figure out your password
they'll stay on target what used to be
my knowledge may be old and I'm not a
cyber guy by the way but they used to
stay on target roughly 15 minutes before
moving on so when someone's attacking
let's say a small business website it
will sit there and run through 500
different characters but if your caret
if your password is 24 characters or
longer then it would take roughly 15 to
20 years for a supercomputer to break
the code 15 to 20 years right because
you're going beyond
it's like combination locks right the
more numbers you put in the longer it
takes for someone to crack it and then
it gets to the point where no one can
crack it if even the most experienced
thief trying to get into a manipulation
type lock right so and what is that
level to get to that point it's what
it's just keeping it even more technical
or going more than 24 letters 24 or more
20 orders characters yeah and so now
what you're doing is putting time on
your side because it can't sit there and
run against your it can but it won't run
against your password all day every day
because then we're if we're the malware
comes from or the virus comes from will
then be detected and they don't want to
be detected so the goal at the end is to
run a 24 character password or more on
everything you have
and then you are defeating a lot of
those types of hacks
where are you storing your passwords so
meaning what do you recommend so
nowadays we got 50 login 40 logins right
is there anything you're suggesting
where or do you suggest same password
for all 40 50 do you change a mob
because it's a lot of work right there
it is
so I mean there's a lot of different
tricks one yes there's apps out there
that will maintain and even create very
complex passwords for you and keep track
of all that I'm not one of those guys
I'm still kind of old-school I keep all
of my passwords right here but what I'd
have done is in my system I have the 24
character phrase then on the back end of
that I will put the word that relates to
whatever it is it goes into so if it's
my cable provider and I want to login
it's the phrase and cable then it's the
phrase then Bank I don't use specifics
I'm not going to put you know what's a
cable company verizon fios right I'm not
gonna put it I'm not gonna put anything
that specific but I will put cable then
on my next one I will put Bank if I have
three banks that I have to login to bank
one bank to bank three they're all at
the tail end of the 24 character that
way I don't have to remember so much but
yet I'm still bulletproof the other
piece of this equation is your username
a lot of these a lot of sites will make
you believe that your username has to be
your email address right but it's worth
trying to make it something other than
that right because that is typically
easy for the bad guys to figure out is
the username but it is a crucial piece
to them getting into your accounts so
treat your username like another
password make sure it's just make it
something that isn't related to you so
that that way now it doesn't matter
right if you've got a great password and
you're not using your email address as a
username they're not getting in and then
the other the third piece to this
equation at a personal level is two part
authentication it's become very popular
anytime you have the opportunity on your
emails banking everything make sure you
turn it on a lot of them ask you hey do
you want that sure is it an extra step
that sometimes a pain in the ass yeah
because you got to wait for the text to
come through and you get your six digit
number and then you put it in but yeah
that's better than someone else getting
in I agree you know one of the things
that happened to us last year is one of
our Instagram accounts got an email
saying you're about to get verified okay
and click on this and the person clicked
on it and then we went to it and then
after you went to it it was never from
Instagram and so one of our employees
that's working you're just basically
thinking okay one another account that's
getting verified let me go out there and
do this and then it was someone else
that stole the account changed the
password email saying if you want your
account back I want ten thousand dollars
from you yes and they're doing that now
so they're doing that with Gmail they're
doing that with Instagram they're doing
that with Facebook and one of the ways
that I was told is check to see if it's
at Facebook if it's coming from Facebook
right not Facebook customer service
you know Los Angeles that's not Facebook
you have to look at that as well that
was another area that they were talking
about which happened here for us any
other item on cyber security that you're
seeing as a threat for folks out there
to be thinking about on how they can
protect themselves you just hit on the
big one so passwords being the
vulnerability and then of course people
clicking on the link that they shouldn't
and so that's either spear phishing
where they go after someone like you a
CEO CFO kind of guide the popular scam a
year or two ago was it would appear as
an email from the CEO to the CFO saying
I need you to transfer that's that's
what that's what just happened six
months ago right and it's handed
multiple times in the last six months
we've caught it every single time
good yeah you'd be surprised there's a
lot of compile Beth oh yeah because the
email address looks like it's coming
from the CEO when in reality it wasn't
but it's like giving I need you to
transfer the money right now
and then some of those CFOs listen to
their CEO and they transfer the money
and then it's gone forever
so yes look at those email addresses but
I also tell companies all the time you
can make your signature block part of
your
security protocol right any email that
comes through make sure there's
something special about the signature
blocks that all the employees use that
way if someone from the outside tries to
pretend to be you you can look at a
signature block and go nope that's not
someone within the company back in the
day you could do wallpaper or watermarks
you probably still can you know through
some of your email exchanges so you can
put a wallpaper to that's specific to
your company so that everybody knows
that's internal email and it is legit
whereas if it came with just a white
background in the email then you know it
isn't the other thing I want to talk to
you about is the anonymous emails you
said number 58 sending anonymous emails
what did you mean by this on sending
anonymous emails leave zero forensic
trace back this level well so privacy
has certainly become a big issue right
there is a lot of people that don't want
marketing issues or marketers trying to
get in and what we hear about it all the
time now right that Alexa is always
listening here about Facebook is always
watching so what it is is that's giving
someone the ability in a very simple way
to increase their privacy and anonymity
when they're online so it walks you
through on how to download things
properly not utilizing any of your
personal Wi-Fi or work Wi-Fi download
some apps go through a couple of steps
and before you know it you've created an
anonymous world that you can now do
whatever you want to do without worrying
about whether it's Big Brother Facebook
Alexa or anybody else watching so it's
just to increase people's security based
on privacy alone excellent good we'll
keep coming back to a couple crazy
things you got here that's non-stop it's
one after another okay next one so he
said technical cyber next one you said
health active-shooter let's talk about
active shooter right so what is what is
starting to happen is we we have
increased our security here
ever since we've noticed what's been
happening you know having a security
person now we're training on active
shooter what happens when that happens
and when we're in a military your your
training different methods of what
happens and there's a lot of different
philosophies with active shooter one
says you go the whole zigzag if you see
somebody when it happens in a movie
theater or at workplace and another one
says somebody should attack the active
shooter because if you don't attack and
they can spray everybody in the room and
at least one person can stop them
what are your philosophies and views on
how to handle active shooters you know
it's a little bit of everything you just
mentioned so the mantra that's become
very popular and it was it started with
a video produced by city of Houston then
it became the the federal kind of iconic
run hide fight video and it's been
passed around it's only about five
minutes long and I support that
philosophy one because it's easy right
run hide fight the words define
themselves but I like to caveat that
there's actually more to each piece of
it right one the environment you're in
dictates what you're going to do the
situation that you might find yourself
in also as part of the decision-making
process so if it's a run I tell people
all the time
don't just run like aimlessly right if
you see a herd of people go by we all
have the mammalian reflex that says oh I
should run with them your job is to
counter that feeling and stop for a
second
look listen pay attention to your
surroundings and determine where the
gunfire is coming from because here's
the one thing most people don't tell you
is gunshots fired indoors is much
different than gunshots fired outdoors
when they're indoors there are about a
hundred times louder okay that's number
one number two the sound ricochets off
the hallways stairwells walls you name
it so it makes it omnidirectional so a
lot of times in an active shooter
scenario when the shots are fired
indoors people inadvertently run towards
the shooter because they think they're
running away from it because the bang
sound was from their left
right but the shooter is actually to the
right that's a good point
so in those situations before you run
you want to trust your eyes question
your ears especially indoors okay so
that's number one running in a zigzag if
you find yourself in the open right and
there's no one around there's no cover
then ya be erratic with your movements
right run like a crazy person because if
it's just you and the shooter you want
to make it as difficult on him as
possible because by running in a zigzag
forces him to change his elevation and
his windage right elevation is moving
that barrel up-and-down windage is
moving it left and right so you want him
to have to really try and get you but
the odds are you're not going to be the
only one but if you are zigzagging then
he's gonna redirect his attention too
much easier targets and as horrible as
that sounds that's how you survive then
when it comes to the hide I tell people
all time the hide should be looked at as
temporary at all costs it should be
temporary and you should run from cover
to cover cover is anything that stops
bullets concealment is something that
still hides you but it doesn't
necessarily stop bullets all of these
things you can identify well ahead of
time so you mentioned your work
environment you've increased security
but the best thing every employee can do
is identify the things that stop bullets
now while you have plenty of time and
zero stress the last thing you want to
do is make decisions with increased
stress and zero time because the odds
are you're gonna make the wrong decision
and end up dead so it find your cover
now which is structural pillars you know
dense wood weight before the event
happen right start learning about your
work environment now right because we
all live in a very small pattern of life
we're at work or at home our favorite
coffee shop the gym whatever in all of
those environments that you're at the
most those are the environments you
should start looking around going okay
that 45 pound plate yep that'll stop
bullets yeah that granite whatever
desktop I can flip that over get behind
it that'll stop bullets or that
structural pillar that's in my building
you know that's dressed up to look like
you know doesn't look like anything
special because it's got sheetrock it's
decorative then you know obviously
architects want those structural pillars
to blend into the environment but
they're everywhere you just got to
identify them ahead of time so if you
find yourself in a room or what a dead
end that is a bad place to be right the
bathroom dead end a closet dead end
so your movie theater and death
situation as well if you only have two
exits you're up you're shooters at the
bottom you can be in a dead end in that
case title right so now it's about
getting out of sight so that you're not
in their sights but if you find yourself
in a room know how to barricade a door
properly there's some a little bit of
physics and science to it but you stack
things in front of an inward opening
door linear so it's desk right against
the door then behind the desk is another
desk table chairs whatever extend that
that line of furniture all the way to
the opposing wall and let the opposing
wall be your brace against the door make
sense now no one's getting it mm-hmm
if it's outward opening doors and a lot
of commercial environments you have the
automatic door closer at the top it's
like an elbow joint you can take your
belt off wrap it around that elbow joint
nice and tight now it makes it difficult
for the guy to get in but not impossible
so you have to keep that in mind what
you're doing is buying time and that's
why I say when you hide make it a
temporary thought process meaning as
soon as you get in there you're
immediately looking for your next out so
if there's windows throw a chair through
the window out through the window you go
head to the tree line head to a
neighbor's house head to you know
another business building but get out of
the building is the number-one objective
because the X it's all about getting off
the X you being a military guy you know
this just as well as I do the X is the
point in which your adversary decides
they have the greatest advantage where
you're most vulnerable where speed and
stealth benefits them most your job is
to get off the X as quickly as possible
so schools are the X some work some
places of work are the X sometimes your
home is the X your job is to get out of
there and you know to get out of there
as quickly as possible into safety
the final piece of the equation is fight
and a lot of times for the average
person that should be the last resort
right and when you fight you're fighting
for your life meaning you have to
increase your violence equal to or
greater than your Abbas or adversaries
in order to win so fight fight fight
fight for your life you know and use
improvised weapons if you can if you're
at work team up right so if you know
he's coming you're in a dead end you
have no other outs and there's just two
of you you're gonna make a quick plan a
little bit of leadership someone's got
to find the courage and we all know
courage is just as contagious as panic
so do not panic because then others will
start to panic powerful right courage
pick courage every time even if you
gotta fake it till you make it yeah ten
that you're brave and you will be brave
so when those shots get closer and
closer to your door and when that muzzle
comes through the door number one man
the weapon is the priority get control
of that weapon number two man is going
for the hip to the head if we talk about
MMA in the fighting world we know that
the way you control a body is by
controlling the spine the best way to
control the spine is either the pelvis
or the skull the pelvis is a bigger
target and when you have stress right a
ton of stress and a ton of adrenaline
it's better just to go for the big
target because going for the head might
seem a really small token in that time
in your life right so number one man's
going for the weapon total control
number two's going for the hips separate
the adversary from the weapon and then
if you have the opportunity you can use
the weapon against him or everybody's
gonna dog pile the bad guy and keep him
down on the ground and tell the first
responders arrive Clint how often do
companies call you after the fact when
an incident like this happens how often
do people hurry after something happened
I've had a few but you would be
surprised on how many companies
culturally won't even let the words
active-shooter be said even today why is
that they they just still don't want one
they don't want to scare their employees
so it's a very
critical decision point for a lot of
your global security directors and Human
Resources on whether to really train
people on this because they're afraid
that the messaging is something bad is
coming something bad is going to happen
why would they train us on this unless
they're not telling us something and
sometimes those thoughts of senior HR or
senior security is what prevents them
actually from making a move but we've
navigated those cultures by switching
the language and can be a violent
intruder it can be aggression so there's
a ways to teach a workforce without
saying those words that might be kind of
culturally scary to really and you're
seeing that and we are seeing that even
today with the with the amount of media
and exposure that active shooters are
getting there's still a lot of companies
out there that don't really want to say
it out loud now let me ask you for
company side how many times is it people
attract and get where yet you said
something you said the last thing you
want to do is make a decision during a
crisis I think this is something you
said in one of your interviews I'm
assuming you were saying that because
you're trying to say you want to be so
prepared that you don't need to make a
decision it's just instinct purely
acting on it is that kind of what your
point was behind not having to make a
decision in crisis correct oh yeah you
want to basically act out decisions that
you've made a hundred times hundred
times before got it
so is there anything companies can do to
prevent any situations like that happen
meaning preventive measures not even you
know let's prevent any of this stuff to
happen that it can never happen at our
company or is there no matter what you
do can still happen at your company yeah
I mean I remember going to this FBI
profiler right and a lot of those guys
have quite the education in psychology
and behavioral sciences and I found it
pretty interesting that he pretty much
laid out that 10% of any demographic so
that could be a company that could be a
state that could be a country you're
going to have 10% of the population
that's going to have what he called
dangerous personalities right and so
if 10% 10% of dangerous potential
dangerous personality traits so that
could be someone who's got a little bit
of sociopath in them someone who's got a
little bit of psychopath in them and
there was a long list of what is
considered a potential dangerous
personality trait so no matter how much
you vet in your hiring processes no
matter how many screening processes you
go through in the military there's a
good chance that there's 10% ish of
people that you're around that could
have those traits and could activate
them or they could be triggered whether
it's you know their own personal crisis
going on in their life or it could be
that they went down the path of you know
substance abuse it really it really
varies what the triggers could be so
it's difficult to say hey how do you
just prevent it you there is no way to
just totally prevent hiring a potential
active shooter but what you can do is
give your people the emergency
preparedness protocol and training so
that when it happens it increases the
odds of survivability for everyone got
it that's that's good to know you know
it's uh it's it's coming up again more
and more even in businesses where people
are asking me about what we can do to
prevent this from happening next secure
homes okay so you're living in a house I
saw a couple of the clips where you're
looking at the exact you know format of
where the house is this is the bedroom
this is an exit this is this this is
that before we been going to that are
you a fan of safe rooms like you know
buying one of these ten $20,000 safe
rooms or the underground ones are you a
fan of those I would say I think they're
pretty cool I think if you could create
a safe room then sure why not I'm not
and I'm not buy by any means what would
be defined as a prepper I'm not paranoid
I'm probably somewhere in the middle I
would say that anybody getting out of
military these days are a little hyper
vigilant it's probably the best way to
put it but I think the odds real
they are the is what you go by right
what are the odds of having a violent
crime inside your home you know they're
pretty slim to none depending on your
lifestyle but as a hobbyist creating
these safe environments that could
potentially be life-saving if one day
you just happen to be put in that
position right because let's face it the
element of surprise is the one thing
that we're all never expecting so you
have to respect the element of surprise
even if it's in your own home and you
know why not put something together over
time that could give your family and
yourself a safe haven if something bad
happens yeah I look at a lot of
properties here in Dallas one thing
California doesn't have is they don't
have what do you call it what would he
call a basement California doesn't have
a basement right Chicago Midwest a lot
of the homes right have basements so
it's it's you can kind of set up like
snow earth exactly I kind of help you to
put that in there too you know tornadoes
no tornado California doesn't have that
either but you know some of the homes
you go to in Texas you're like you know
we have a safe room here we have this
and you're going to you're like well
what for incase you know there's a lot
of tornadoes so you got to be prepared
for it and you're seeing it I sometimes
wonder if there's a level of
effectiveness to spending that twenty
thirty thousand dollars to put that in
your home or no real reason to put it in
there the other thing would be safe
where is a good place to put your safe
in your home is there any place you
would say is a good place to put it I
would say any time you're trying to hide
anything you put it in the place where
no one's gonna look and for depending on
a home or where you live you know
sometimes that's in plain sight
you know because let's say a bad guy
going after the safe you know I don't
know what the odds are in that anymore
be honest with you most your violent
intruders or people that come for your
stuff right so two kinds of intruders
there's the guys that come for your
stuff and there's the ones that come for
you the ones that come for you tend to
come at night the ones that come for
your stuff come during the day while
you're at work and most your
neighborhood is gone during the day so
that's the best time to come take your
stuff and they've got more time
they've got all day to sit there and
pillage through your stuff but if a safe
in itself I mean put it in a place where
no one's going to look when I think
about hiding a safe in a more
traditional it's like okay the master
room closet no one will look there right
or I'm gonna put it put it in a recessed
place in a wall behind a picture mmm
that might still work these days right I
mean especially we got a lot of pictures
that's gonna eat up a lot of time for
that guy to find the one picture with
the same or even better yet put a safe
behind every picture in your house but
only put your good stuff in one of them
so that they are like what the hell we
got a hundred safes to figure that
budget right there yeah how is easy to
break into safes nowadays you see these
videos about how to break into safe is
it is do you trust the credibility of
having a safe where a guy that trying
trying to break it into it you know it's
very slim to none I think that's an art
that has come and gone first of all to
manipulate a lock open
takes a great deal of skill okay and so
that's a more of a locksmithing father
this father to son trait that's been
passed on for generations so I don't
think that's gonna be going on but there
are autodialers that you can buy off
Amazon that will sit there and dial
every combination possible over time and
if the auto dialer gets lucky the lock
will open early but if it happens to
dial the last combination last in the
auto dialing series that could be eight
hours later so is a bad guy gonna rely
on that kind of odds to get into your
safe probably not now will he just grab
the thing and yank it out of the wall or
try to pull it out take it home and then
spend a week getting it open yes right
so if you're gonna have a safe make sure
it's permanently bolted to something so
that makes it difficult to leave and
then once again make sure the
combination on it is more than you know
four to more than four characters
typically on a manipulation lock these
days you've got bio
biometrics they can open it which is
great just make sure it passes the
gummybear test I mean
you put your fingerprint on a gummy bear
put the gummy bear on that biometrics
and there have been some very cheap
biometrics that will open their test
with the gummy bear fingerprint you know
so make sure it passes the vote the
gummy bear test but another important
final piece to safes is you have safes
that are meant to be secured and then
you have safes that are meant to protect
your stuff during a fire so if something
is good at protecting from a fire it's
not necessarily safe in a safe that's
good at keeping people out isn't
necessarily great for a fire right so
you have to keep that in mind yeah
that's a good point right so if you're
gonna buy us safe you have to really go
with all right what are the odds we're
all together
don't put your valuables at home keep
them somewhere else Clinton are you a
fan of uh getting your license to carry
the average citizen to get a license to
care like actually taking a course going
through the process I I am I think
but once again it you need to be
proficient with that weapon right you
need to put yourself through your own
personal quarterly you know or as many
times a year training hmm whether that
be instruction from others you know
experts in the community or even just
going to the range and shooting but more
importantly if you're gonna carry to
this day before I walk out of the house
I practice drawing because that's the
one thing most people don't do and it's
literally yeah like you have a mirror in
my house and I will like draw at least
five times before I walk out the house
natural for you you do this every day
just muscle memory just get you know
making sure that your hands Bioman
biomechanics is a big deal and under
stress your body's gonna rely on muscle
memory and if you've never done that and
then all of a sudden you're gonna go
grab that gun your guns gonna fly out of
your hand or the holster is gonna be on
the end of the gun so by doing that
allows you to walk through all of those
little issues that you couldn't find as
you first start drawing like the holster
flying off yeah the gun flying out of
your hand or your magazine falling out
because you didn't have a seated
properly I mean there's a hundred things
that can go wrong when you draw that
it's very true
so draw draw draw be proficient if
you're not gonna do any of that stuff do
not carry a gun cuz no one wants anyone
out there carrying a gun you don't
somebody who knows how to use it you
don't want them out there that don't
know how to carry a gun no the right the
point being is a lot of people go get a
concealed permit yeah and then never go
shoot just because you have a concealed
permit does not mean you should be
shooting that gun and the last
perspective yeah unless you are
proficient with that weapon once the
quarter go cuz in the military I don't
remember how often we wanted a range was
it once a quarter was it once a year you
went to the range I don't remember the
exact number but you have to go and
requalified regular yeah you should be
at the end of the day you should be
drawing and dry firing on a regular pace
right you can sit there in your house
draw that weapon and shoot at the
television right no no bullets just dry
fire and be in that will do more for you
than shooting paper at a range no good
places to hide your guns at the house in
case somebody breaks in any specific
spots or is it the same typical under
you know the TV set that's holding it
any any specific places you have because
especially for a family who's got kids
mm-hmm anything you know from experience
yeah I always tell people access is the
priority not access access is the
priority being able to get to it is more
important than that actual concealment
factor we talked about yeah I got to
hide it here hide it there but the
reality is when you when you put it all
these hiding places
that's not exactly convenient when you
actually need it especially in a in a
you know life-threatening moment you
certainly don't want it you don't want
layers of things in the way in order for
you to grab that weapon so be smart you
know there's a lot of quick access
digital biometric gun safes that you can
actually put right into a drawer you can
bolt it to your nightstand at least that
way it's right there the safe and then
all you got to do is put your fingers on
it and it opens and you grab your gun
and go I think access to the gun is more
important than the concealment part if
you have kids then your access is going
to be out of arms
rage of a child right so I can grab a
gun from the top of my dresser on top of
it because I know that my kids or kids
visiting my home can't reach that spot
right so you just gotta it's common
sense but you know we both know common
sense isn't so common these no no doubt
about it
absolutely I agree that's why I wanted
to ask you do you carry yourself
regularly or not you usually carry him I
do carry regularly yeah I mean I I
practice what I preach as much as I can
unless I'm getting on airplanes or you
know any place I recommend here any
school you recommend to anybody anybody
that you would endorse most of the guys
that I refer people to are you know all
over the country everybody tells me
about the Vegas thing that's going on
you go there for three days it's real is
it hand shooting courses yes out of
state yeah there's a bunch I could refer
you to there's there's Dom Rosso he is
like the owner NRA poster boy he's a
former command member where I was at and
that guy puts on a great course there's
Ronin tactics who was a former CAD guy
who does incredible stuff and he's
always traveling the country there's
another guy up north
he's also travelling they all of them
come to Texas every now and then so it's
it'd be a good idea go to their websites
check out their dates sign up for one of
theirs but they're all tier one guys
that are teaching you you know guys
there's no [ __ ] way to do I like that
instead of kind of like you know so
Clint I saw some of the stuff you had to
make weapons in an office if somebody
wanted to I know I got a newspaper here
I got some duct it was not really the
best kind of duct tape
I got an appoint and a soft show us a
few things on what someone can do to
make a weapon that goes quickly out of
these the first things that come to mind
is a newspaper bat now the newspaper bat
was actually made popular by hooligans
that used to go to soccer games overseas
the security at soccer games overseas
have become very very good because those
guys like to beat the [ __ ] out of each
other when someone loses right so the
security is learned to really actually
Pat people down make sure no weapons are
coming in so what do these guys do they
start bringing newspapers because if you
take ten pages of a newspaper or more
and you
you open it up like so we're gonna do
this very quickly just for you here and
then you roll it diagonally and the idea
is to get as much air out of your future
bat as possible so we're gonna start and
we're gonna get it nice and tight as
much air out as much air out all right
so get it going we're not doing a good
job but you get the point so they
literally do this in Europe they're
really used to do this in Europe now I'm
pretty sure they don't even let
newspapers anymore because of this
technique and then you give it a good
old fold now if you happen to have you
know a good old duct tape what's great
is it can hold it in place and increase
its density for you when we talk about
you know arms swinging right an arm
swinging like a punch it is usually like
25 miles per hour as soon as you put
something in your hand depending on who
you are your strength your flexibility
mobility and your joints you can now get
up to about 50 miles an hour with
whether it's a newspaper bat like this
right and to get hit put your hand out
to get hit with something like there's
no joke
right holy moley you totally feel you
can hurt somebody with this yeah it
would it certainly could knock somebody
out and it's just a newspaper if you
want to take it to the next level roller
quarters you know these days it's rare
to come by this stuff right change is
slowly gone away and cash is not even
really available these days right we all
carry cards and we pay for stuff with
our phones but number one you can put it
in your hand increase density helps
increase velocity just makes your punch
have a little more you know yes or once
again if you want to increase the
velocity substantially you throw it in a
sock and now you can really hurt someone
I mean this is an improvised sap really
at the end of the day the beauty of this
is if you're a traveler traveling abroad
it's always good to have change overseas
because they're still taking change it
tolls overseas they're still taking
change at parking meters so it's good to
have change and a sock you separate
these two and you're not carrying a
weapon right bandanna off also something
you can carry but if you were to take a
fishing weight and place it in the
center and then roll it up an 8-ounce
fishing weight is great and there's
they're gonna feel it you know you're
gonna feel it eight ounce is gonna knock
someone out so you have to be careful
with you know any kind of improvised
weapons especially if you're playing
around for fun because let's face it you
just saw a newspaper can be dangerous
enough to give someone a concussion
certainly knock them out so but if
you're in a bind they certainly could
potentially save a life if you're in a
bind if you're in a bind
taking a newspaper and turning it into a
weapon there you go so a couple things
with you you you were talked about
elections you've talked about some of
the hacking stuff with China
how are you viewing somebody that was in
on how some of these other countries
look at us right now if we look at
what's going on with the economy I'm on
the finance side so I see what's going
on with the trade wars we look at what's
going on with sanctions with Iran we see
what's going on with Venezuela the
brexit all of this stuff from your
standpoint of regimes and powers how do
you view how China looks at us from your
experience I think we all know that's a
symbiotic relationship right to a
certain degree we need them and they
definitely need us economically I'm not
up to date probably as much as you are
on you know the interest rates over
there but we know that they are slowly
going under I'm talking businesses that
were thriving just a couple of years ago
but I do I do think that they are still
a threat regardless of that relationship
of us needing them them need and them
needing us mainly because of the numbers
right they've got a lot of people and I
always think alike the Red Dawn
situation right how easy would it be for
them to
put a hundred million people which is a
very small portion of their population
what parachutes on their back and fill
our skies right whereas 100 million
people is a third of our population
right that's the kind of that they've
got the numbers now do they have the
infrastructure no I tell people all the
time the easy way to determine the the
economy of a country is look at the
satellite imagery of the earth at night
right the infrastructure is defined by
the number of lights on in people's
homes and in you look at the earth night
all the lights on in Europe it's bright
you look at America the whole country's
lit up now you go over to China there's
not much light right you go over to
Russia there's not much light so if you
really want to understand a country's
economy at its simplest is just look at
how many lights on are at night here we
can afford to leave our lights on 24/7
and everybody has access to electricity
but that's not the same when you look at
Africa China Russia so when you get
scared about the economics just look at
their infrastructure through pictures
when a simple way of looking at it
though and you look at my books I like
pictures right so all my books have
pictures because really that's just it
and for me it's simple I'm not that
smart of a guy but you look at the earth
at night you look at the infrastructure
and in that self just that alone defines
a country's economy but you know how
every country has certain a way they
were locked for me I was born during
revolution so there's a certain level of
a rage sometimes that you meet a Middle
East I'm from Iran because what they've
overcome is the fear of another person
taking over control all this other stuff
right you see somebody who escapes
Russia from the communistic regime
you'll typically see them where
sometimes they're like well I don't know
listen sometimes in Russia you have to
break the law to make money when the
communism was there because we couldn't
tell everybody so it's like you gotta
learn to keep secrets you don't tell
everybody your business you see somebody
from China maybe when they first come
here first generation here you have to
listen to everything the government's
don't push the envelope then do this
sometimes these are folks that tell you
this is the community I'm coming from
but I'm more talking about from the
standpoint of their aspirations of who
they want to be I heard you say
somewhere I think wasn't some kind of an
interview or talk you were given where
you said they will either meddle with
our elections or they will spy on us and
then five years later they'll tell us oh
by the way we're planning on doing this
or something like that what were you
referencing with China when you talk
about that do you remember that I think
what that was relating to is we usually
don't detect them in our networks
they've usually been in our networks to
upwards to five years five years they've
been there when you see before we
realize what do you mean by that that is
I'm talking if you've if you're a
company if you're a fortune 500 that
deals in technology and you've got
intellectual property then the potential
of them being inside your network right
your cyber world your intranet that is
securing all of your secrets as a
company there has been times where when
the investigation comes later on they
realize that they've been in there for
five years before they were actually
caught and I think that's what you were
kind of referring and that's what I'm
saying is a lot of times when you talk
about hackers in the cyber world you
know they are on the offense which puts
us always on the defense
they are always creating the ways to get
in and then we are always playing
catch-up on creating ways to keep them
out they is China or Vegas hackers they
is hacker okay yeah I mean you
geopolitically we know that there are
state-sponsored hacking going on but at
the end of the day it's hacking now a
lot of times they're hacking and
collecting all this information you're
like what are they doing with it right
OPM they you know you heard about OPM
the Office of Personnel Management for
the government you know I was one of
those guys that got a letter from the
department from the Department of
Defense that said oh hey by the way when
the Chinese hacked OPM you were one of
the people that they collected all your
information right my my personnel jacket
you know potential medical information
I mean you name it it's a fire why do
they want to know stuff lon well that's
the that is definitely the multi million
billion dollar question and I think I
mean edit you know in my small little
brain it's like well if we just collect
collect collect and then they aggregate
all that information and put it into all
these different little folders you know
maybe one day someone that's running you
know for a certain political office you
know ten twenty years from now well
they've already got a whole bunch of
information on them that might not be
exactly something that person wants out
you know do you think it's that you
think they're going today I just says
that's pretty deep strategically I
always kind of think like yeah well what
they do with my yeah right I fully get
that because there's an aspect of
control and influence and being able to
sell that to somebody else I mean that's
the whole right uh you know conspiracy
or hearing about why Epstein was was he
killed was he not I mean you know I
asked uh Sammy the bull Gravano I said
is there any way that he could have been
killed he says the section there if he's
staying at the place I'm thinking it's
very tough to commit suicide it's not
easy because the ceilings are not high
he's explaining this whole thing but the
fact that say pepsin had so much
information on everybody else because
all the people that would go with him on
the island he knew the name so people
were not wanting this guy to have access
to that information because he can
potentially disclose the info to
essentially get immunity like hey leave
me alone I'll disclose everyone info
kind of leave me alone but do you think
there is the meddling going on with
election you think this is something
that's continuously happening I think
it's I think it's very possible because
I mean I think the investigation proved
that ads were paid for by foreign
entities in those ads popping up on
Facebook and Instagram or articles that
weren't real you know that you have a
large number of people that leverage
social media for news and when they read
it they believe it and then the reality
is is no it's not and I can only base
this on my personal experience when I
was in the military and if there was
something I was part of that made the
news 85% of it was exaggerated wrong or
wasn't even close to being accurate and
now that I'm out
it's all I have to go by I look at it
and I go well probably 50 to 85% of what
we're seeing isn't exactly accurate
right it's all about clicks these days
it's all about sponsorships advertising
marketing you know we know the deal
right but the average person doesn't
know that and so their lead astray
through what they get off social media
when you know they just need a little
bit of education that what you see on
there isn't necessarily true that is
true and and you know you wonder if it's
because I think this one's gonna be a
very ugly election next 12 months I
foresee this one being uglier than the
last one and the last one is already
ugly and marketers are just getting
better and better and better at it so
it's gonna be interesting to see what
happens with this election coming up so
let's let's talk a little bit about your
new book that's coming up the right kind
of crazy so what is the right kind of
crazy you know that's a that's a title
we toyed with right there's definitely
the wrong kind of crazy which you don't
want to be the right kind of crazy I
think describes a lot of people who go
in the service right they have a taste
for risk they know they want to travel
they know they want to do bad things to
bad people I think there's a lot of
reasons especially these days or
especially after 9/11 why people join
the military and want to go overseas hmm
and it does take a certain amount of
crazy for people to jump out of planes
put themselves in harm's way
get in firefights blow things up right
so it's the right kind of crazy that is
what we need and is what we should
desire to go against our adversaries
overseas so that's more of an umbrella
kind of term it doesn't necessarily
apply to me it applies to anyone serving
and that's the right kind of crazy but
built into that is that even though you
have this whole professional life of
risk what this book proves is that some
of that risk can spill over into your
personal life it's almost automatic
because when you are living and
breathing the special operator life
which is nothing but risk 24/7 in
training and overseas and sometimes you
end up inevitably taking risks in your
personal life that you know could be
characteristic of not such a good or
great guy right and so is that because
you think you can get away with it and
it's kind of like the itch to say I know
I can do this and get away with it it's
kind of like another project or is it
just the environment of what your Iran
for too long of a time bleeds into you I
think it's a little bit of both okay I
think it is I think both are one in the
same is that you are you're living on
the edge in one environment and then in
the other you're supposed to be this law
abiding citizen right and the two really
don't match because when we go overseas
we are breaking every law we don't stop
at checkpoints we do not stop for law
enforcement right and we're carrying
guns when we're not supposed to be
carrying guns in countries that we are
not citizens of so when you really look
at it that way and now you come home and
all of a sudden you're supposed to
follow all these rules it can be
difficult because you're living and
breathing that in order to stay alive
and then in your personal lives right
you're overseas you're pushing the
envelope now you're pushing the envelope
in your personal life and it can make
for a nightmare in your marriage or
personal relationships for some guys it
leads to substance abuse they end up
going and finding something to fill that
void that they're not getting because
they're not at work right now
and so chance your question yeah it's
you end up becoming a risky person but
more than likely if you went into that
job you already were that way too right
that's interesting you're saying that
because I I think I heard you saying one
of the places we are sociopaths this is
most guys who are willing to do what I'm
doing as a Navy SEAL most of us are off
a little bit how did you describe that
like yeah I bring up I I did and a joke
at a manner I do think we you know you
you have the traits of a highly
functional sociopath that was the word
yeah meaning you know you're not gonna
have remorse about some of the things
you do really what that means is hey I
don't have an emotional connection
or a feeling of consequence to the
things that I'm doing right I'm gonna go
do it and I'm gonna succeed I'm going to
win and there are no other options
and I'm not gonna feel one way or
another about it and so whether you're
born that way or their traits that you
slowly start to inherent once you're in
it in the military or in the Special
Operations community it's really boils
down your way of compartmentalizing the
things you're doing so that they don't
affect other things in your life but
some guys have harder times of
compartmentalizing it than others
favored military movie I'm curious I
gotta say man Full Metal Jacket that
first half still just it makes me laugh
it makes me like I mean there are so
many parts to that first half that I
kind of relate to I admire the the
verbage the fact that every other word
is [ __ ] because that just takes me back
home yes as you know as a sailor and as
a seal especially that is note that is
definitely part of our daily voc
vocabulary so I yeah I love that a lot
of hard was it for you to stop saying it
I mean when you became civilian was it
was it hard to count cuz you know when I
got out my buddy when I started working
at Bally's manager pulls me said it says
listen I got to tell you you can't curse
this much so what do Thomas is I'm
telling you cannot do this is non-stop I
said I'm not cursing anybody it's an
adjective
this has have been speaking for the last
three says you can't talk like that in
this place here you know you're not
gonna have a long career with them but
was it hard for you to adjust from it
was it just kind of a you know natural
turnoff to cameras on you know drop the
f-bomb it yeah it does come a little
naturally when I find myself here with
you I'm not saying it when I'm around my
daughter I'm not saying it yeah but
every other aspect of my life it just
comes out as not real as the word though
yeah yeah it's it's almost like a I
remember when we joined the Army when I
went to my unit I became the guy
would initiate new recruits and it was
my favorite thing to do some of the
stuff I did was just terrible but it
would they knew it
h1s one would tell is it s one s one
would tell me that new recruit is here
perfect chow hall sit him right in front
of bed David it was sitting in front of
me and we would start with all these
pranks and some of the pranks we pulled
on these guys were absolutely terrible
to do that till today I get messages on
Facebook saying I don't know if you
remember this or not do you remember
that one time you did this with the
Playboy magazine to me it took my
clothes away and you and I'm like I'm so
sorry buddy it's been 22 years but I
remember that I apologize but these are
some things we did back then but you
know that old culture of camaraderie
pranks you know it's a culture you miss
when you leave all right it's tough to
kind of find in the civilian world did
you ever have any challenge about the
PTSD yourself or not really that didn't
do that had didn't have an effect on you
you know I I dedicated a chapter to both
hazing and also PTSD which you could get
from the other but uh you know I was one
of those guys sitting in the squadron
space when I was in and I was making fun
of the guys I would definitely call it a
crutch for a very long time like all
these guys whatever you know they're
just trying to basically get a hundred
percent disability collect a check I
felt like it there was a lot of
financial drive behind claims of PTSD
and I shouldn't have because I had a
grandfather with it and uncle with it
and I shouldn't have looked at it that
way but for some reason when you're in
and your active duty you tend to kind of
look at things I would say far more
aggressive than when you get out but it
wasn't until I got out that I found
myself on my you know runs you know as a
I like to run so but I would find myself
getting lost in thoughts that would drop
me on the spot emotionally I would stop
I mean because I would think about
things that I had somehow once again
compartmentalize put it away and just
did not think about it and then it
started coming more and more and more
and the reality is is when you live a
life
120 miles per hour and you go from a
hero to zero when you retire right and
you come to a screeching halt all that
luggage has no place to go but hit you
in the back of the head right and so it
hit me like a freight train the buddies
that I lost and never went to a funeral
you know other tragic events that I had
forgotten up to the point when I
remembered it right years later I'd go
like crap I'd totally forgotten about
that and but the bottom line is I think
that hero to zero that transition period
you're very vulnerable and if you don't
talk about it and and let it all out
to someone it doesn't have to be a
shrink heck it can be you know during an
interview on a pond yes but get it out
so that you can continue moving forward
and reinstate your hero status even
though you're a zero at that moment in
time yeah I mean is this in the last
four years when you got out yeah oh so
post when you got out as a moment you're
running and you get emotional right
thinking about some of the stories right
you all of a sudden find yourself
thinking about a guy and then you
realize wait he's dead yeah or it could
be you know to this you know like a lot
of guys you know our cell phones we have
you know a lot of guys in there and
you're scrolling along and all of a
sudden you see that name of your buddy
that you can't call anymore his phone
number is still there his name is still
there but he's dead you know so it's
weird those moments creep up on you when
you least expect it and then but I feel
like you know talking about it goes a
long ways yeah I I agree again my buddy
called me told me says Pat I'm telling
you I'm dealing with PTSD and that for
some like what are you talking about you
know you're a tough guy are you serious
Pat I'm telling you this is really
messing with my head and then one day I
had a commerce it was late at night I
had a conversation went for an hour and
half I'm like he's really having a tough
time with this you know I kind of put
myself in his citrus and now I get it he
saw some stuff somebody some things like
maybe I could have done better you know
because some of those situations like
the regret of saying what if I could
have done this better what if this what
if that but
you know it's interesting you describe
it the way you do I definitely do know
that there's a lot of good guys I was
asking you about the local guys elite
meet what they do there's a did they're
heavily involved with Navy SEALs guys to
help out with it any other movies where
you said this movie really you know is
believable in the life of who you lived
and what you did oh for what I did yeah
oh yeah I mean Charlie Sheen and Navy
SEALs I mean come on you go you know
it's pretty funny there was a lot of
seals that advised on that movie and I
think a couple of them were jumping out
of the plane you know for some of those
scenes it's it's it's funny when you go
back and watch it now because that was
coming out I believe I was in high
school or college when that can't can't
remember and I went we gotta saw it and
I was like wow you know because I wanted
to I've wanted to be a seal since I was
10 years old you know it from Ted yeah
I'd met a seal in an airport you know
try it when I was traveling abroad it
turns out he wasn't a seal he's a total
fraud and that's why there's this I
guess who I don't know who came up with
it but at 360 to one fraud versus real
right so for every 360 guys out there
saying they're a seal one of them is
actually legit yeah it's probably one of
the most fraudulent occupations on the
planet and it didn't help for a time
there Maxim magazine was putting in this
who do you want to be at the bar thing I
don't know if you saw that and so every
month an issue would come out and they'd
have a full-page almost like info
graphic write it have a drawing of some
cool guy and I'd say this month when you
go to the bar to pick up chicks you can
be whatever I one of it one of those
months you was you can be a Navy SEAL
make up who you are essentially right
what you're saying right it was all
about it was just these short little
things about how to pick up chicks and
this is who you are and I have to think
that maximum magazine spawned the
fraudulent guys that are out there these
days because you'd be surprised how many
texts I get from people ago hey is this
guy CEO hey is this a guy seal and what
these guys don't know is that we have a
database that we can go to and search
them right and nine times out of 10
not in the database Wow yeah and that's
the guy who inspired you go but it was a
guy he was totally fake and then it was
until once I was in the military asked
around did some research and turns out
that everything he told me was just all
[ __ ]
yeah so so we're on a flight and Marr
you remember this and this lady sits
next so did you go there as well or no
marios sitting this lady's like so what
is it cuz we're going on the flight and
it was one of those flights where you
have to get down at the tarmac and you
walk there was two planes okay so one is
going to Santa Barbara one is going to
Phoenix so we know we're going on the
right one to go to Phoenix area so we go
to the one in Phoenix
and there's a lady sitting next to me
and a lady sitting next to Martine I
said man I can't wait to get to Santa
Barbara this is gonna be a good trip and
the lady's like what do you mean this is
gonna sound a Barbara Mario but that
hesitation like he had this one going to
Santa Barbara and she starts talking so
so what do you do for living it says I'm
military and then she became all
emotional like listen thank you for your
service you know such any Mars I'm
feeling bad I'm not experienced it well
that was a whole different prank
situation that led to Mario said I got
to you know I'm not I'm just I'm in
marketing I run an insurance company
anyways
yesterday we were sitting there watching
a few good man you know the scene where
he's like eh tell me the truth etc etc
and you go back and forth and Jack
Nicholson said if I told you the truth
you wouldn't believe it in my nor orders
you can't handle the truth that whole
scene I asked my dad this question I'm
Kherson of what you say about it do you
think he had a point to say you need
somebody like me to lead the military
because if you really know how ugly it
was you wouldn't be able to do this job
do you think partially he is right to do
the job that Jack Nicholson was doing
essentially being a commander of marine
there are some decisions you can have to
make that's going to be tough do you
agree with that part of it completely
yeah yeah I think you need guys like
that that make the hard decisions like
he said and on top of that act on them
right and that's the part that you know
a lot of the people on the outside
watching you know kind of is the
fishbowl effect and armchair
quarterbacks that don't get that part
I mean there are a lot of decisions that
you certainly have to make a lot of
times under stress that you at the time
are hoping is the right one and then
when it's all said and done you go okay
good that was right there's always the
potential for it to be the wrong one and
it can't necessarily always be you know
that person's fault because let's face
it I mean the circumstances sometimes
are overwhelming and you're just happy
to have gotten through it you know and
gotten through it alive but on the
battlefield I mean for a long time
anything goes and then and then a jerk
and then and then attorneys got involved
right attorneys play a big role on what
you can and can't do now no matter what
the operation is unfortunately and so
the movie wasn't all that inaccurate
because it's an attorney right putting
this decision maker that makes decisions
under stress and in war on the stand and
in reality it is attorneys that drive
rules of engagement and what we can and
can't do overseas in real life yeah I
mean it's when I would talk to the
old-school guys in the military you know
guys who had been there for 30 years and
I'm 18 and like yeah let me tell you how
this army was you know it's for sissies
today when I ran it was this and it
would tell some stories we're like wait
a minute literally like this is yeah
that's how it was before so Wow I mean
that's it's tough to believe on how much
tougher was partially some of the stuff
that they're doing probably is good
today to make it what it is but some of
the stuff they're doing you can't really
toughen up I believe you can toughen up
soldiers like you once did because you
got to be very careful what you tell
them now it is because if you don't you
know they could come back and say wait a
minute this is he made me feel
uncomfortable he made me feel unsafe
there's some of that going on today
which I don't know how you can control
that but you know sometimes you need to
give the drill sergeant the flexibility
to be tough on people but it's not as
flexible as it wants to I agree which
are fortunate we talked about this
briefly Joker what was your takeaway
from the movie Joker Joker I thought
as a performance man I thought he did a
great job performance wise did he bring
to life into art into today's reality
how mental health can certainly go from
something not that aggressive right his
mental health issue wasn't something
that was threatening until people
started pushing certain buttons and then
it flipped and he became a murderer
right so I thought it was good in terms
of shining a light on how mental health
and the people that have it can
certainly be triggered or flipped by a
lot of people you know that they're by
people they're surrounded by that could
potentially be rude be inconsiderate or
just not understand I think we just have
to remember that and I think that's what
the movie shined a light on is you just
never know what a person is truly
dealing with right and it doesn't take
much for some people with mental health
to flip that switch all of our jobs
these days especially is we don't
necessarily need to flip somebody's
switch just because you need to say
something rude or you just need to get
it off your back but you need to have
the last words or you just feel like
insulting someone whatever that is and
trust me me being from an alpha male
world we all want to say stuff do you
have a routine nowadays now you know
you're a different age today than when
you were first and I have my own system
that I try to tap into it what's your
system to kind of calm your nerves down
in that moment um I think it's it more
of an internal de-escalation it's like I
asked myself really Darkman is it worth
it
am I being a good representation for my
daughter you know by acting like an
idiot no so I usually if I think about
you know my daughter or the people I
care about most
Kazu demo brings you down a couple of
notches because it or is it worth going
to jail for because these days we know
that even if you do the slightest thing
that comes off potentially go violent
yeah yeah you're gonna I mean I'm a big
walk in Phoenix guy I think he's one of
the most incredible actors we have today
I like his interviews
when he does interviews with David
Letterman said I'm gonna go into hip-hop
or if you if you ever want to entertain
yourself you just gotta watch Joaquin
Phoenix's interview he says the most
random things I was confused whether he
was aligned with Heath Ledger that's the
part that for me was a disconnect I
didn't feel that a brilliant mind like
Heath Ledger who can run the underworld
the way he did
who could put strategies together I
didn't believe the Joaquin Phoenix Joker
could be him no I didn't think he was
that guy where I'm like this guy's a
genius because Heath Ledger to me comes
across as brilliant as a genius and
walking then walking came across to me
as watch what I'm gonna do to you
revenge fine but to take you to that
level I didn't feel that strategic part
of it and then I also thought it was a
very divisive message I think the last
thing we need is a message like that
today in America was all about dividing
the rich and the poor we're you know
some of the theaters in New York where
the rich people were getting shot that
people in the theater were cheering them
on and they wrote an article about it
well you guys got to kind of calm
yourself down I thought it was a device
it was a movie that divided the nation
more I think we need a little bit of
more Rocky movies today you know rocky
boy where rocky said look if he can
change I can change if you can change we
can all change we need a little bit of
synergist today we need a little bit
more Rocky today and little as a joker
today that's my opinion though I'll
leave it at that final thoughts here
before we finish off the interview here
with you what are your final thoughts
with your book with your next projects
you're working on with how people can
find you what projects you work on with
CEOs executives companies who hire you
tell us a little bit about that yeah I
think I try to maintain one lane and
that Lane is crisis management yeah
emergency preparedness that's it and so
a hundred deadly skills like we've
touched on certainly gives good people
what you would call bad guy skills right
it's important for people to know how to
be more self-reliant more self rescue
capable and that's ultimately the goal
now with my company escape the wolf that
is
really going into corporations in
building OSHA compliant policies that
also hold up in court that proves that
they are providing a safe work
environment and acts as an anchor so
that you can train the workforce so we
build custom videos we have already
pre-made packaged videos that can deploy
onto their servers and they can get
their people trained in a smart way
giving them just the information they
need to know and not without all the
other you know data that that is the
reason why people get bored during their
online training at work we try to keep
ours very entertaining but yet
informative so in a nutshell you know
it's all about getting people to take
some ownership in their own personal
security and safety both at work and
also at home and that's really that's
really it in a nutshell and people can
go to escape the wolf comm if they're
interested in us coming in and helping
them in their organization or they can
go to Clint Emerson comm for the rest of
my ecosystem of things I'm going on so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna put
the links below to everything he's got
going on links below 200 deadly skills
also links below to your book that's
coming out the right kind of crazy and a
website Clint Emerson and the other
website you mentioned we'll have that
below if you want to get a hold of them
contact them on any of the information
that we have below if you have an order
to book order the book as well and with
that being said brother thanks for
coming out and doing thank you with us
but I really enjoyed it
thanks for having very insightful great
hanging out I cannot be a bad guy if I
wanted to so if you enjoyed the sit-down
with Clint Emerson I got two other
videos I want you to watch one of them
is with Chris tanto paronto the real
life character from the movie 13 hours
which is absolutely hilarious you know
this guy was actually one of the guys at
the Benghazi issue that took place at
the embassy he tells you the story his
version of the story then another video
that I did titled 19 military lessons
that helped me become a millionaire very
deep content I sing in this one I cannot
believe when I watch it today I did this
two years ago saying what were you
thinking when you were singing I was
trying to sing R&B in this video so
anyways
any one of these two videos that
interest you click on them and if you
haven't subscribe to the channel yet
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
[Music]